if you're talking about civilized in
terms of well-mannered like set up stray
responsibilities just kind of being you
know I guess stiff upper lips oh no no
there's a way tougher than southern it
[Music]
hey how are you doing I'm good how are
you I'm not bad thank you very much have
you eaten in Manchester and Liverpool
some smashing places right well I
haven't I haven't been that far north
what to me I just feel like the south
and in London and his homey place
there's just so much more because you
just know you do know you just you just
sorry what the North has is some amazing
like really beautiful country pubs to
amazing home-cooked food you don't North
is just like same old same out it's like
okay what does that mean Hubbs
it's like South you've got like Thai
food Asian food Korean food this you
know you've got the world cuisine and
then oh no in the north it's just like
egg
[Music]
get me out people go like when a on a
night owl or you know they get like wild
I feel like it's it's to a point where
as northern as I like like that one time
I went to Leeds in and out oh my
goodness
Leeds trade station Friday night carnage
absolute carnage and I was like what is
this
this feels post-apocalyptic okay firstly
some people will just call a commitment
and secondly that doesn't exclude us
from being cultured it's just not just
about going out and whether you get
hammered or not you know there's so much
more to it than that but to me I feel
like it's no even a case of like
northerners are you know uncivilized I
think it's just the North has its own
culture I feel like there are attributes
that are just like to the north and I
feel like if you're talking about
civilized in terms of how you would
initially think of it like you know well
mannered like sit up straight you know
responsibilities just kind of being you
know I guess stiff upper lip like sorry
no no there's a way tougher than
southern mmm-hmm
stiffen it one time we got our minds not
any more but like we did
[Music]
I'm a traitor to where um I'm an
absolute traitor growing up it was
breakfast dinner and tea right at school
if you called lunch lunch then people
would think you're bad you have to call
it dinner no yeah but I think you would
have liked okay if you're having like a
hot meal yeah you would have like a hot
dinner right they have if you brought
your own lunch it would be a packed
lunch and we call it lunch time my
teacher to say or the bell would ring
like okay it's lunchtime it's not
scrammed time it's normal for a time it
was just like I can't I can never
understand that like well I'm a bit
confused by your insistence that we call
it scram because because although of all
the words it's like it just like just
shows a lack of education because
scratch means scram just means any foods
it's amis it's not particular meal scram
just seems like anything like leftovers
like rat food like
[Music]
hundred-person what do we know about
just everything I feel like southerners
will moan about the tube the tube or
like you know taxes or you know money or
it a time to rich I'm in the South right
blue but northerners will complain about
everything like right
the number-one thing is like the weather
like the weather always have that horse
for others like this
this person's like I feel like not just
so negative negative negative I'm like
oh yeah but the thing is you've got a
bear in mind the well there's a lot more
changeable in the north so it's a big
topic conversations not grim
it's just changeable
[Music]
what the hell
Wow my goodness this is like scram times
ten
no million words for a roll bread roll
you call a roll that's the most generic
boring interesting oh my gosh why do you
choose to name a bread roll like ten
different things to be yeah you can have
a million things to like you could have
a whole new it is nice because it
inspires loads of debate amongst
northerners it's quite something and it
kind of defines where you're from it's a
little jazzy little takeaway thing that
you know people discard range if you
like if you go into the chippy hmm you
want us Richard bomb absolutely are we
missing out no more I wouldn't even get
that role from the chippy I just say
fish and chips period I don't even say
sure low carb I get it right and
southern I do think that southern
chippies which I'll rubbish by the way
oh that awful
moaning you wouldn't know moaning oh my
god you wouldn't know as you say to
actually go to the north
we're in the south have you been besides
London Brighton Hastings John to list
places have been to well do because I
feel like the north is just like one
place and I feel like this half is like
all these little pockets of things
no the south is London and then a few
tag ons around the edge of it also Essex
is a tag on what did you describe it as
before the whole of London back garden a
baccarat stand on Essex is the name we
are a reality TV capital of England
I don't even know why you devoting this
that's ridiculous frankly you know I'm
I'm gonna put myself here okay cause who
were the biggest band that have ever
existed the Beatles from the north who
else have we got
oh we've got Oh a sis we got Arctic
Monkeys let's face it were better at
music well valid valid point the North
has chand out some stars but look at
like the current like who is the most
successful music it's Adele - Erin no
from the UK I feel like there's some
strong ones in the north but we've
turned out or some like in the south
because that's what I'm saying cause I
feel like the North's music is like it's
amazing but it's missed a yeah I know I
know what you mean there is that element
to it I do get that but I also think
that there's a certain edge to music by
northern artists that maybe just rough
yeah you know I just think makes it
preferable to me also ed sheeran once
said something disparaging - what I
makes about scousers so you know oh
so obviously I'm not going to be
resentful a little bit yeah
[Music]
so I'm in the group that the Midlands
don't exist I don't believe there are
Midlands I think there's a north and a
south and anyone who calls themselves
the Midlands just compaq aside
oh yeah the Midlands are just a
nonentity yeah I was saying they don't
need to pick a side cuz I don't care you
know there's a reason we're not sat here
today debating Midlands versus north or
Midlands versus south because they don't
like have that much of an identity so
it's not worth bothering about
I did this reluctantly before you like
just go crazy at me because I think it
depends on so many circumstances okay
right so you're a no no I go on berate
you for disagreeing with that statement
because I've chosen to live here there
are certain opportunities in London but
quality of life and having a bit more
freedom because financially you've got
more freedom the North definitely allows
for that mm-hmm but then again you say
about quality of life I genuinely bred
something that was like your average
southerner has a higher life expectancy
than your average northerner why I don't
know but it's almost like ten years what
oh my god so I think it just depends so
it's I haven't learned that is how big
my oh my gosh you just added a whole
thing is
[Music]
it's funny to joke about it yeah at the
end of the day I'm a northerner we like
nice people wherever they're from it
doesn't matter I would never dream with
you
pretentious cheers - that's just
northeast South not the Midlands though
Midlands only this don't even yeah why
is it wrong how many people go on on
Port Arthur is nine ninety percent of
what the population yeah sure
have you been on one side expose yeah
well you know I'm a person as well
you aren't yeah